who got stuck paying two
mortgages uh you know that idea kind of
scares me we just got out of um consumer
debt
so the thought of going back to
yeah you're not gonna do that you're not
gonna get stuck because you're not gonna
buy a house unless that one sells
so the way you would go about this would
be
put it on the market
and then accept themselves except
accept an offer contingent upon
contingent upon or subject to is the
phrasing your ability to find a property
that is suitable to you and your wife
within 30 days
and then you go shopping with the 150
000 that you effectively have in your
pocket
okay so i'm out of there you don't like
the house and it's got ghosts of
boyfriends past and
um
you know i'm out man there's a lot of
reason to check out this deal now here's
the thing you're selling in an up market
and you're going to buy in an up market
so
just be ready for sticker shock right
yeah be sure you can get a house that
you will like that's within your budget
correct would it be smarter to rent and
then kind of wait and see if the market
goes down i don't think the market's
going to go down
it might slow how fast it's going up
but it but i don't think it's going to
go down the number of times the real
estate market the residential real
estate market in
akron ohio has gone down
overall is i'm one time in 50 years
2008.
okay you know it just doesn't go down
much sometimes it's kind of
sluggish and slow and it's not
increasing much but you really don't
lose value in real estate very often
it's very very unusual a single family
to lose value now you can get in a bad
neighborhood or you can run the
maintenance down and mess up the thing
right but but in general if you maintain
real estate in a decent reasonable
neighborhood in a decent reasonable town
which akron certainly is then you can
you know you can pretty well be assured
it's going to go up it's just lately
it's been going up at white hot
rates it's kind of hockey sticking you
know up and to the right so
that's a problem but but guess what
you're selling in that market and you're
buying in that market so you just give
yourself some latitude and you know if
you go out there for 30 days and you
absolutely can't find anything then you
you have the right to step out of the
deal you've made that deal in your
contract and you've not messed anybody
over
now dave in a hot market like this are
there sellers who go i'm not going to
take that deal where it's contingent
it's not a seller he's the seller yeah
for the for on the buyer's side but they
would just be contingent upon
simultaneous closings all and they're
there's not you know close them both the
the same day and it shouldn't be a big
deal i mean it might be there might be a
buyer who wants all cash no
contingencies
no appraisals no inspections there's
people doing stuff like that but you
just can't buy that house because you
got to get yourself to close yeah
but you can find you know you can find
people that'll sell a house contingent
upon the
closing of yours that's under contract
that's really not especially in a hot
market it's not that big a contingency
it's not that big a problem so
it'd be different if it's contingent
upon the sale and hadn't even put it up
for sale yet that one's a little tougher
but uh in in a hot market like this
open phones triple eight eight two five
five two two five rogers in san antonio
hey roger how are you
hello dave thanks for taking my call and
how are you all better than we deserve
sir what's up
well let me give you a quick rundown and
then my question is about my wife and i
both being 75 and wanting to protect
our assets the quick rundown is we have
zero debt on anything way to go uh
retirement
thank you retirement income is around 98
000 five which is net
and um let's see we have 93 000 invested
in five stock funds uh through two
investment companies uh we have over 370
000 in uh cds bonds and fixed annuities
uh net worth is about 1.4 million
risk outlook and that's the reason i'm
calling but we spend less than we make
uh we're very if not ultra conservative
and we want to protect what we have no
high risk no high yield type of thing
what's the other million in
uh two houses and land okay
okay so you you worry about risk
um but you still managed to put together
a million for
in net worth way to go so what's your
question uh
well we've got uh this money that's uh
98 uh no correction 93 000 in
investments and then over like i said
370 and cd bonds and fixed annuities but
cds are now insultingly flat and so
we're trying to say well what do we do
with cds that are coming out of maturity
now
i've got one for example for 122 000
that's out just as a couple days ago
and um so we're wondering what would be
the best thing given our very very
conservative risk level uh go to what
would i bonds be one thing for example
no
no i mean you can do whatever you want
to do but here's the thing you're taking
two kinds of risk if you don't outpace
inflation in taxes you're losing
purchasing power
so that's one kind of risk and you've
been accepting that kind of risk for
quite a while with these stupid butt cds
and these underperforming bonds you're
talking about i'll tell you what hang on
we'll talk about this a little bit when
we come back from the break i want to
make sure we unpack this beautifully for
you cause it's a really good question
george campbell ramsey personality with
me today open phones at triple eight
eight two five five
two two five
[Music]
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over 800 a year go to
puretalk.com and choose the affordable
plan that's right for you with their
30-day risk-free guarantee you have
nothing to lose go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save 50
off your first month
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
our last live show of the year before
christmas is always the giving show the
giving edition of the ramsey show and we
need some stories from some of you that
have been on the receiving end of
someone being very generous and it
changed your life or helped you during a
rough time or whatever and maybe you
were on the giving end maybe you tipped
a waitress a hundred bucks or you gave
thanksgiving dinner to a family that
couldn't afford it or maybe you paid
somebody's light bill for a year i don't
know what you did
but generosity is the highest and best
use of money
and so we always want to encourage
generosity it's why we teach you to have
some money
and uh so we're gonna do this show as we
always do a giving show it's a one of
our uh ramsay show traditions and if you
want to be on the giving show and you
have a great story we need your stories
we need you to come on
uh so what you do is you go to
ramseysolutions.com
ask
ramseysolutions.com
ask and put giving in the subject line
kelly and the production team will be in
touch with you we'll get you on the air
make you part of the deal we're talking
with roger in san antonio rogers 75
years old million for net worth got 93
000 mutual funds 98 000 income 370 000
in underperforming cds and bonds and so
forth wanting to know what he can put it
into with virtually no risk because he
hates risk is that a fair summary of
what you told me so far
yes sir that was right right on okay
thanks so what i was saying going into
the break is there's two kinds of risk
one is the risk of losing the money
which is the risk you're worried about
putting it in something and it goes down
in value or worse than that it
completely evaporates to nothing
and that's the great fear of someone who
is risk-averse i'm risk-averse like you
are
okay but sometimes in an effort to avoid
that kind of risk we embrace
fully another kind of risk that we
didn't even realize was there
because the average inflation rate for
the past 72 years has been 3.2 years 3.2
percent according the consumer price
index in the last year or so it's been
of course a whole lot more than that
we've got crazy inflation with all kinds
of weird crap going on with whatever the
economics mess is that we have right now
and and so it's even worse but let's
just use three percent you know 3.2 or 4
4.2 right in there somewhere in there is
about every year we see a
gentle increase in prices over the years
you're old enough like i am to have seen
that so if you don't make that plus the
taxes
on the investment
you're not even breaking even
and so you need to make about six
percent on your money or you're losing
purchasing power you're losing money
every year
and so if you're not running fast enough
away from that kind of risk but not so
fast that you run over the cliff
on the other kind of risk you'll get
tackled from behind and that's what
you've been experiencing this 370
thousand i'll give you an example of
that how how poignant this is can you
imagine what four million or 400 000
would be worth um
15
16 years later
if you left it in a coffee can
well i can tell you it would be
1.6 million
is what it should have been in a decent
something making 10 percent that's what
it would have come out
and if you left it in a coffee can you
know it's got it's 400 000 so you lost
1.2 million in potential growth during
that 16 years by burying it in a coffee
can a cd is not much better
yeah that's true
so that that's what i look at now having
said all that i'm not a gambler i don't
like losing money i work too hard for it
so i'm not playing any fad stuff i'm not
done i'm just looking for tried and true
stuff and so and i'm thinking about what
my timeline horizon is and okay so if
i'm going to leave the money alone a
year
what's safe if i'm going to leave it
alone three years what's safe i'm going
to leave it alone 10 years what's safe
and here's the interesting thing if you
look at just for instance a simple uh
index fund an s p 500 fund if you leave
it alone five years the number of times
you actually would have lost money is
less than three percent of the time
and the average annual rate of return
would be north of ten percent
average
that's a ten-year horizon that'd make
you 85. but here's the thing you're
likely not going to touch this money
it's likely you're investing it for your
kids
yes sir that's true
so your grandsons yeah so you have a
10-year
horizon
or a five-year horizon you know you
don't have a short-term need for this
370 000.
so that's why at 61 as a risk-averse
person i'm very comfortable when i have
a long-term
time horizon investing in something like
some conservative
very easygoing boring
mutual funds
and all the get rich quick guys make fun
of me but then you're just a boomer
ramsay you don't understand you're an
antique dinosaur you understand how this
you don't understand how all these get
rich quick things work yeah i do i've
lost my butt in them i know exactly how
they work and so i don't do them anymore
i don't like risk so anyway that's my
pitch
so you're saying hey you can move this
370 000 over some conservative mutual
funds and the chances of you losing
money over a five-year time horizon very
slim statistically historically and it's
less depressing literally than putting
it in the cds or the bonds so that's the
move where's this income coming from
roger the 98 000
uh 98 000 is um by civil service
retirement uh air force reserve
retirement and a little bit of social
security cool so you're not touching any
of these funds anyways you're going to
be able to live off of that
for the rest of your life what's the
what's the guarantee on all that income
obviously all that'll be there yeah
there's nothing no that's going away
thank you for your service yeah by the
way yeah thank you so here's another
thing that helps me with risk
and i'm not again it's not a gamble and
i'm not i'm not putting the money up
there but here
if let's just say
that uh you picked the worst mutual fund
in the history of man
and you lost all the money and you're
not even going to put it in one fund so
this is not possible okay
let me tell you how many growth stock
mutual funds have gone completely broke
to zero
none
ever
okay because all those companies that
they own would have all had to been
worth zero
so you would have had to make like home
depot mcdonald's coca-cola
hewlett-packard ibm and apple all worth
zero is the only way your mutual fund's
gonna be worth zero because all those
stocks are in your mutual fund
okay so but let's just pretend you lost
the whole thing because because i'm
stupid and i don't know what i'm doing
and i told you about something bad okay
so if you lost the whole thing
you've got a million dollar net worth
with a hundred thousand dollar your
income you're okay
you can you can't emotionally stomach
the risk but you can mathematically
stomach the risk
follow me yeah
yes sir conceptually i i'm not depending
on that money uh
actually not not depending on that money
for anything and so it's really going to
go to the daughter and grandson exactly
doing very well exactly so what you've
got to do is you need to
what let me tell you this okay so when i
buy real estate um i buy in my town
where i grew up and i know what that
neighborhood is you know what i'm saying
yes and so i can remember because i'm
old i can remember when that house sold
for a fourth or a third or a tenth of
what it's selling now when i drive down
the road i mean i saw the house for two
thousand dollars when i was eighteen i'm
61. that house is 242 000. or 342 000
now i know that right so i can look at
the history it's just in my it's
imprinted in my brain because i've
driven past it so i'm looking at the
historical data on that street i've
watched that neighborhood go up or come
down deteriorate or clean up or
re-gentrify or whatever's happening i'm
watching the historical data on the
neighborhood and because it's in a in
quotes air quotes good neighborhood
and it's got a historical
25 40 50-year track record of going up
in value
i don't think i worry about my real
estate
so
my point being if you're gonna do what
i'm suggesting take your time and really
understand with your smart investor pro
or with your investment advisor uh the
history
if you really look at the history and
say how many times on this mutual fund
in the past 30 years would i have lost
money
you know if you looked at
uh investment company of america ica one
of the biggest funds ever or fidelity
magellan one of the biggest funds ever
if you just i'm not recommending either
one of those but they're old funds and
they're huge
if you go back and look and say okay
over 40 years or 50 years
under what scenarios would i actually
have less money than when i started
you're gonna get really comfortable
with that level of risk once you see the
historical data like driving down that
street in the neighborhood yeah go sleep
better at night roger do the math
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're ready to get out there and
find a job you love then you need to
hear this
job hunting can be stressful and time
consuming but my friends at ziprecruiter
have made the whole job search way
easier ziprecruiter is rated the number
one job site in the us by g2 and it's
free so how does it work first go to
ziprecruiter.com
ken
then create a free profile and let their
technology do the hard work by finding
and sending you jobs that are a great
fit and get this zip recruiter pitches
your profile to companies whose jobs
match your skills and experience if
someone from that company likes your
profile they can personally invite you
to apply for the job so if you're ready
for an easier job search check out
ziprecruiter sign up for free right now
at ziprecruiter.com
ken that's
ziprecruiter.com
ken sign up today absolutely free and
let
work for you
[Music]
[Applause]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt-free stage anthony and katie are
with us hey guys how are you how you
doing good how are you welcome welcome
so how much debt have you guys paid off
132 000 dollars all right how long did
that take how long did that take 19
months good for you and your range of
income during that time 95 to about 140.
cool where do you all live personville
good for you good for you and um what do
you all do for a living i am a pharmacy
data analyst
and i finish cars oh good good for you
all perfect okay so what kind of debt
was this 32 thousand
congratulations credit cards yeah credit
cards car loans if there was a store
that had a name on it we had a piece of
plastic for it yeah um just all kinds of
dumb tool bills everything
wow
so you're normal
all right so what happened uh
24 months ago to start this 19-month
journey
oddly enough i was i was working and i
was working on a car and that was back
in the day when facebook would just play
videos
and i had my phone over on my toolbox
and
your music came on and i
for some something told me in the back
of my mind don't skip this one because
normally you know growing up in
nashville you hear about dave ramsey and
all this well
for some reason something told me don't
skip this one i played it and it was
somebody that was going through the same
thing as we were and it was their
debt-free stream oh wow and i believe
that was
the first time that god spoke to me yeah
and went home and told her hey you know
there's this there's this process that
we can do and
you know maybe it'll work for us
and one step at a time um you know
started in january because
we rolled into the the new year
making good money
with nothing to show for it right right
it's old it does get tired of being
tired yes you know and and and then you
hit then you had a pandemic right yeah
in the middle of trying to do all this
right now that's fun
yeah did that help your income or hurt
it it helped me i work in health care so
at one point i was working three jobs
yeah i bet and the pandemic didn't
affect me the tornado did because oh
where i was working it caved the shop in
ah
so yeah we were out of work for a few
months until they found a place to set
up shops so to speak well they rebuilt
it yeah oh they had to rebuild the whole
thing oh my gosh that's wild so you guys
were kind of on on a spending spree and
you got to this point where you went we
can't live like this anymore what kind
of sacrifices do you have to make were
you selling things i know you were
working some extra jobs there what kind
of things happen for you guys to feel
the progress on the journey
i'm the social butterfly
so
not going out to texas roadhouse
every week and not going out with
friends and not going to concerts and
that kind of stuff is is what we
sacrificed really you know if we made
that a step in the baby steps texas
roadhouse would become very offended
just target them and go you can go
somewhere else but you can't go to texas
roadhouse you can't do it
i like it you had a texas roadhouse in
your house it sounds like yeah okay we
brought it home making plans with
friends you know we tell them we'd love
to hang out with you but instead of
going and spending 40 dollars to go eat
and tip and all this why don't we'll
coach something we're trying to hang out
we'll play cards yeah and we had you
know a group of very solid friends that
were on board and very
supportive with that
because it was all about the fellowship
it wasn't necessarily about going out to
eat it was just the social aspect of
being together exactly and going out to
eat is not really about the food
you know because you could buy that same
food for about 10 cents on the dollar or
what you pay at a restaurant if you're
just cooking it you know and probably
probably a better food in a lot of cases
no offense to texas roadhouse but you
know there you go not a personality you
just have to throw peanuts on your own
floor that's all i'm saying who's
cleaning that up not me
wow so it sounds like you guys had some
great cheerleaders did you have anyone
that thought you were crazy for doing
this thing oh yeah of course we had we
have people that said you know there's
no way it'll work um you know there's
it's it's it's ultra philosophy it's
outdated you know you can't do anything
without credit or leveraging debt or
anything these days but then you know
comes around may and i'm like hey i'm
gonna sell my truck and let's uh let's
move this on so
sold a beautiful duramax that i had
to uh carvana and now i'm driving my um
you don't like it being called a dave
carson my beater okay um i'm driving a
uh a 2002 buick riddle
the high life
touchdown yeah yeah well now you don't
need debt and so now you can start to
save up and buy and drive anything you
want to right bigger bigger plans than
that um a big proponent of what actually
kicked this journey off is
do you mind if i okay
it's uh it's fairly emotional
but um
for six years we've been dealing with
infertility
and we're looking at doing
in vitro fertilization which
every attempt is 15 000 or more dollars
yeah yeah and um better investment than
a duramax yes yes we'll get better
returns 100 i like this yeah cool that
that is our that's wonderful that is our
why
hey that's that's uh you get freed up
you can do that and then it doesn't
break the bank so to speak you know and
uh sometimes they hit first time
sometimes they don't hit first time and
it's not gonna be the end of the world
emotionally it'll be a roller coaster
but financially you'll be able to do it
right
yeah pretty cool i'm so proud of y'all
that's an awesome goal thank you very
cool i can't think of anything better to
do with money than babies
it's about the best thing you can do
with money that is a good investment
they'll take care of you if you treat
them right well hypothetically i don't
know about that part if you take care of
them and treat them right they will
bring you grand babies now that that's
what makes it worth it but yeah if i
don't know how great grand babies are
going to be i've been nicer to their
parents but there you go so
hey good stuff you guys that's amazing
i'm so proud of y'all okay sum it up
when you're crazy friends that were
making fun of you for being crazy not
the supportive ones the other ones uh
say okay you paid off 132 000 in 19
months making 95 to 140. how did you do
that well you tell them the key to
getting out of debt is
stay focused embrace the suck
because
life sucks either way you know there's
there's
a pair of price right so
sacrifice a little bit for a better
tomorrow instead of
spending your wheels living the same way
day after day like we were
yeah
i can see y'all five years from now with
a big ol pile of money and a couple kids
i can't wait for that pretty cool that's
fine all going a texas roadhouse yes
yeah
there we go
load them up in the buick no the duramax
is gone lord look on the buick we're
going to texas roadhouse i like it and
paying cash by god there you go
oh you crazy man i love y'all you're
amazing it's very cool very cool we got
a copy of the baby steps millionaire
book for you an early release copy
because the book comes out in january
it's on pre-sale right now and we'll
also give you a copy of the total money
makeover for you to give to one of those
supportive friends or maybe even one of
the ones that weren't you can just give
them a hey this is what we did by the
way we're debt-free how you like me now
so there you go hey
was it worth all the trouble absolutely
100 how's it feel now that you're free
free free
just that
very good good for you guys powerful of
it what a rockstar cup i almost said put
a texas roadhouse gift card in the book
that you give to the unsupportive friend
at least they get a meal out of it they
get that one time well you got to put it
on page 62. so you have to read down
into it to find it
yeah that's good i like this this is
good fun fun all right anthony and katie
nashville 132 000 paid off in 19 months
making 95 the 140 didn't skip the
facebook video count it down let's hear
a debt free scream
three two one
how it's done
i love it that's how it's done well a
high percentage of these debt free
screams are people that have gone
through financial peace university it is
uh
available through
a ramsey plus membership now and uh
including the every dollar premium
version which connects to your bank and
the whole thing runs together the
average family pays off fifty three
hundred dollars in debt and saves twenty
seven hundred dollars in the first
ninety days that's an eight thousand
dollar change
in
position in just 90 days not a bad
return on investment but you got to do
the work
and you're going to pay a price just
like
just like anthony said you're going to
pay a price so a price of mediocrity or
a price to not be
mediocre ramsey solutions.com fpu if you
want to give financial peace university
to someone for christmas or you want to
sign up and say hey 2022 i'm coming at
you baby ramsay solutions.com fpu
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
christy is with us in fremont california
hi christy how are you
hi thank you for taking my call
appreciate it sure what's up so mike
my question is um
i just turned 68 in november and i've
been
holding on to
getting my social security benefit so
that i could maximize it at 70. but now
i'm having people tell me that
do the math you should take it now and
do something with that extra money
because by the time um
it would take me like to age 84 to break
even if i don't take it now i just want
to know your thoughts on that
yeah i'm in the boat of taking it
and one reason is you can do way better
investing that money yourself if that's
what you want to do and depending on
your financial situation then waiting to
get you know a few extra hundred dollars
a few years from now so that's what i'm
doing if i'm you and again when you
crunch the numbers you can see man it's
going to take me a long time to really
roi on this decision and so once you do
that it becomes clear that taking the
money now and having control of it is
going to be in your favor
yep he's right the one thing
the one thing i have been doing because
i was the last birth year that i could
take
half of my husband
so i have been doing that for the last
two years and that's basically been
paying my medicare costs which is great
plus some extra
but i sold my business
um this year and with capital gains and
all that hoo-ha
my medicare costs have gone through the
roof so i'm thinking maybe i should just
take my own benefit and have a little
extra i mean more left over to do
something left amen
amen that's amen all right but
mathematically what george has seen is
right if you didn't do that with it if
you just said the way to do the math is
not i mean you can take it and use it
that's sure i would do that but that's
why i said amen but
if you just took the amount you took the
money now and you invest it from now
until 70. the amount in that investment
would offset the difference and the
extra you would have made if you waited
till 70 to start taking does that make
sense yeah it's like i've i've looked at
it and right now it's the two years is
about um 68 000
is what it would be
and um like say there will be more than
that because you'll be investing it all
along
yeah that is true i would be doing
something wrong with it you end up with
a hundred thousand bucks paying you ten
thousand dollars a year that's 800 bucks
and you're not going to make 800 bucks
extra by waiting until 70.
no no that i'm staring right at it on
this piece of paper and you're
certifying that for sure yeah that's
exactly right so yeah that that's the
way this works if you take the social
security but folks if you do this it's
63 you can do it i mean whenever you
want to do it depending on what your tax
situation is but if you can
aside from taxes if you just take that
money and invest it and say okay in an
investment here's what it would be worth
at 65 versus 63
and here's how much more i would get at
65 if i wait you're gonna get more off
of that lump sum investment income
that that lump sum creates
then you would have extra in social
security payments because the social
security system sucks
it's a negative rate of return and and
oh by the way when you die that hundred
thousand dollars we're talking about
with her is gonna be in the investment
when you die if it's at social security
guess how much you get zippo zero nada
you don't leave it behind they keep it
because well they have to prop up their
broken destructive system that they've
engaged all of us in
it's um social security is the dmv of
retirement
if you just think going to the dmv
and how frustrating and horrible
experience that is that's what social
security is when it comes to retirement
just to help you out it sucks and
they're both both part of the government
so go figure
who knew
government efficiency an oxymoron like
fouchy math all right dylan is in
atlanta georgia hi dylan what's up
hey how's it going great man what's up
oh nothing um i just had a couple
questions for you
okay
um so i've got about forty thousand
dollars in savings and i wanna figure
out what's the best way for me to invest
it
how old are you
24. good for you way to go man that's
impressive
so we got 40k it's just sitting in a
savings account right now
uh yes sir okay and what are you saving
this money for
oh well
i don't nothing specifically i just uh
i had a house i bought a house when i
was 19 years old or 20 years old and
i just made a bunch of money off it and
part of that savings is from that money
and so now that i have all of it i want
to be able to turn it into something
else yeah so are you renting right now
no i'm actually living with my dad while
uh where i'm building a house
but this will be money left over after
the house is built and paid for in cash
not in cash oh okay do you have any
other debt
this is all the debt i'll have okay you
have any other money saved of any kind
uh no this is all i have okay or i mean
forty thousand
like out of what i'll have left over
after i have to put the money down for
the house it'll be about
fifty something thousand but i was going
to keep some of that money for
emergencies
so you need this money for the new house
uh this will be
the 40 000
is money that
i'll have left over after the down
payment for the house but you could put
it as an additional down payment all
right so you have an emergency fund in
place what do you make a year
about ninety thousand okay baby step one
save a thousand bucks baby step two is
debt free but the house baby step three
is your ten thousand dollar emergency
fund you've done it okay baby step four
is fifteen percent of your income going
into retirement you need to start that
now out of your budget 15 of your income
should be going towards retirement
babies at five kids college it sounds
like you're single are you
uh i have a fiancee okay and a new six
month old child okay then kids colleges
and baby step five
and six is pay off your house early and
so this money would be used to as an
additional down payment to get you
closer to having your home paid for and
above your 15
and baby step four and then above your
kids college and baby step five we're
gonna apply everything else to this
house and get the house paid for as fast
as we can because a paid for house with
a hundred thousand dollar income dude
means you're gonna become a baby steps
millionaire very quickly
and if you haven't gotten the loan yet
make sure you do a 15-year fixed-rate
loan and i want that payment to be no
more than a quarter of your take-home
pay so start crunching the numbers see
how much you've got to put down to get
there and the more the better if you can
put 30 40 percent down that's fantastic
steve's with us in indianapolis hey
steve how are you
fine thank you for taking the call sure
how can we help you
okay real quick question we are my wife
and i are in the mid 70s we have a home
in indianapolis in the home in florida
no debt i have a
million and a half
in the market
and my concern is with the buying
administration's policies and so forth
as to whether i should take that out of
the market because i'm afraid of the
inflation and everything else and what
it might do to the market
okay
in in what way is it in the market
what's it invested in
well it's in equities and bonds and so
forth so i would have to put it in i'd
have to keep it in the market because of
any capital gains
but could just put something
a lot safer than maybe equities and so
forth when you say equities you're
buying single stocks
yes well i i've got a uh
a manager that manages my portfolio
of single stocks that's the equities
you're not buying mutual funds
no okay that's what i was asking all
right yeah so you got a lot of risk okay
well congratulations you're a
millionaire well done couple of houses
you've worked your butt off steve
uh yeah how much of this did you inherit
none okay cool all right
well i would begin to gradually move
some of it out and maybe buy some real
estate that you pay cash for probably
going to give you a little more peace of
mind will not give you the return that
mutual funds will give you but it'll
give you a lot less hassle
and depending on what kind of real
estate you buy of course
and so and i definitely would be moving
from single stocks
in a managed portfolio
into mutual funds a million and a half
is tough to have a real wide
diversification with that amount of
money it's a lot of money but then
you've done wonderfully
but i try to be in mutual funds
uh first and then i begin to move some
of it out
into some paid for real estate if you
want to hide from biden that's a better
place to hide than in mutual funds
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host thank
you for joining us america george
campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones triple eight
eight two five five two two five sonia
is in boise idaho hi sonia how are you
good how are you thank you for taking my
call my pleasure how can we help
well um
going for a divorce
oh no
sorry sorry
sorry that's okay how long you been
married
just a short
um four years
okay just
not not long
however
we are both up free
he's cashing me out of the house
which is great so i'm getting sixty
thousand
um
we've just paid off all the debt
not the house but
we don't have anything in savings other
than
the thousand dollars which were
is really nothing yet so with the 60 000
i'm
wondering what to do with it whether i
should
put it in savings and weight and just
rent or put 50 towards a house and place
the 10
for
an emergency fund yeah how old are you
46. okay what do you make
54. okay good for you
all right so you're in pretty good shape
then
financially financially your heart's
broken i mean your checkbook's okay
right
right okay good well that's good news
uh now the mortgage he's getting a new
mortgage on the house to take you off
the old mortgage and to buy you out of
the equity right
correct good because i don't want you on
that mortgage when the smoke clears good
okay great all right so it's a clean
break in that regard uh in terms of the
business aspects of this mess
um
first marriage
no
okay
all right
cool
all right well you're only 47.
so um
uh we'll go we'll let the curtain go up
and take the third act right
all right yeah okay so
this money is for your new life and what
do we want your new life to be i would
recommend as much as your emotions are
there and which means you're a human
being okay because you have emotions
it's good you're not a psychopath
um and so your heart's broken and you
cry and that that's a healthy thing
um that you probably rent for six months
and kind of let yourself let your spirit
get settled before you buy i think you
might
be less likely to make a bad decision
buying six months from now than you
would right now because you're kind of
discombobulated would that be unfair
no
okay
no and you know just get settled in your
job and settled in your stuff and just
get you a little apartment nothing fancy
six month rent and uh you know in the
fourth month of that start looking for a
house
okay
maybe i don't know does that feel better
than just rushing out and doing
something right now while all this
crap's in the air
right well yeah
yes
yeah regardless of what you do you've
got to have that three to six months
emergency fund in place like dave saying
i've i've been where you are sonia and
it's a really hard position to be in and
the best thing you can do right now is
just take a pause and heal emotionally
and let that money sit in a savings
account it's not super exciting i know
but what you can do during that time is
start to save up as well and make sure
that whatever that next house is start
dreaming about that dream about the
future and focus on that and you'll be
in a great financial position to do so
tim's in phoenix arizona hi tim welcome
to the ramsey show
hey guys appreciate you taking a call
how you guys doing better than we
deserve sir what's up good i got a
question that i don't hear addressed
very often my wife and i are both proud
babysit millionaires way to go
i um
i have a term life insurance policy
that's going to expire next april
and i'm wondering if i have to replace
it how old are you replacing it at 62.
okay replacing the 62 is a lot more
expensive than what it was at 42. i
heard the rumor yeah okay
yeah all right and uh well
so i mean the question is
if you die without any life insurance
with the money that you all have does
that money create enough income for her
to live on
yes okay
so you don't need life insurance
yourself insured
okay i was just it was i just wonder if
i should brush you know if i should just
go ahead and get another 10-year term or
not i i do have a hundred thousand and
through work covered that which they pay
for yeah you'll have that anyway then uh
but you know
so your net worth is what uh 1.2 1.3
what's it invested in
mostly mutual funds
and i've got about 400 000 equity in the
house
okay all right and so she can live off
of the income that that has created
correct
correct yeah and are you healthy
yeah i do have a uh origin a little bit
of heart issue but uh but 69 69 these
mutual funds will have doubled again
yes
and so you know every day you live she's
better off i plan on working five more
years
another five years yeah
every day you live she's better off
mathematically
it's a good clarifier i just like i said
i i never i had never heard a dress as
far as you know when is it okay not to
have life insurance when kids are grown
and gone the house has paid off and she
can live off the income of the nest egg
then you don't have any need for life
insurance you have done financial
planning you've gotten out of debt
become a millionaire way to go baby
steps millionaire and you are uh you
know she's taken care of you are
self-insured your need for life
insurance goes away we are so
conditioned by the life insurance
industry to think we always need it they
even named it whole life you're going to
need it your whole life they they've
conditioned us to think we have to have
it you know and the only thing that the
only part of insurance that lasts
forever is their need for a commission
and so it you know no thank you i i you
know i've i'm 61 and i've got hundreds
of millions in my net worth and um i
just now talked sharon into letting it
go
yeah but she had it was just an
emotional crutch and it didn't cost that
much but i'm like you i'm at the point
now that renewing it is freaking
ridiculous because i'm we're about the
same age
and uh you even if you're healthy right
and so um
but yeah it was swi for a while sharon
wants it it had nothing to do with
financial planning it had nothing to do
with mathematics and so i should rather
have that than another diamond
we sure appreciate what you all do
because we we followed the plan and and
uh it worked i mean it's uh you know it
definitely works so
hey we appreciate you man you're what
this economy is all about and you're why
we come down here every day
another baby steps millionaire follow
the plan
self-insured that's what this new book's
about
it's kind of boring
i like boring if it means millionaire
status with no stress
how can i be tim
that's what baby steps millionaire is
all about tim 1.4 million 62 years old
no debt
always and do i need to keep this
expensive life insurance yep
how can i be tim i'll teach you how it's
called baby steps millionaires how
ordinary people build extraordinary
wealth and how you can too but if you
want get rich quick or sexy
don't read my stuff there's a book for
that
it's your book not mine but we don't
know i mean we don't even have that no
no
we don't have that at ramsey
[Music]
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying sixty thousand dollars about
two years after that i got a remote job
that pays me a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars all thanks to what i
learned at bethel tech you could be next
get started today at betheltech.net
and get 000 to 2500
off of your tuition again it's
betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
well if you're a long-time listener you
probably heard a debt-free scream from
somebody that changed their life with
financial peace university and if you've
gone through the class yourself you're
finally discovering some freedom with
money maybe your baby steps millionaire
already
maybe you're just beginning to change
your family tree but you can see where
you're gonna leave a lasting legacy
christmas
don't have to give your loved ones just
more stuff
i need some more plastic stuff that's
what i need from target i don't think so
i would rather have a little hope
a lot of people need some hope they need
a plan that will give them hope where
they can see a light at the end of the
tunnel that's not an oncoming train
maybe a gift of a financial peace
university membership would be a great
idea on ramsey plus
yeah
they'll earn the proven plan to get out
of debt save money become wealthy just
like you did and outrageously generous
like you are
and now financial peace university of
course is a ramsay plus membership item
and so uh you can jump in there and take
care of that just go to
ramseysolutions.comramsiesolutions.com
solutions dot
slash fpu our question today comes from
blinds.com find out for yourself why
blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings you
get free samples free shipping and new
promos they run all the time you're
gonna save even more use the promo code
the magic word
ramsay
to get the best deal today's question
comes from eric in rhode island i'm 28
years old and i've been living with my
parents in the since the pandemic began
during this time i've paid off over
fifty thousand dollars in student loans
and a car loan however i still have
approximately seventy three thousand
left in student loans to pay off i make
a little over 65k a year at my civilian
employer and serve part-time in the
national guard usually bringing home 15k
a year i'm afraid of moving out of my
parents place for two reasons one i
don't know how i will pay off my debt in
timely manner and two i fear the only
places i can afford will be undesirable
locations do you have any advice you
could offer me
yes
we do have advice that we can offer you
so you're 28 years old you're making 80k
a year and you've got 73 000 left in
student loans and you've already been
paying on you paid off over 50k
so you absolutely can pay off this debt
in a timely manner
uh the fear of living in an undesirable
location well you can quelch that by
getting a roommate and undesirable
i can handle undesirable if it means
long-term gain if it means i can get out
of debt faster now if you're talking
about unsafe that's a different story
but if it's just somewhere you wouldn't
want to live for a long time that's okay
you're not going to live there a long
time
so you're going to live on nothing and
if if that means getting a roommate or
staying at your parents place i'm okay
with that i mean you can easily get out
you make 80 000 a year there's no reason
you need to live in their basement any
longer uh but you can pay this thing off
in 18 months two years max making what
you make so there's not really any
excuses here other than you know
decision paralysis
eric let's pretend that you're
we're going to fast forward way up into
your life and you have a daughter that
is 24 years old
and when you think of your daughter your
smile she's your little princess
you've raised her she's smart
she's self-sufficient
does she want to date you when you live
in your mother's basement
do you want her dating you if you're her
dad
answer is no
so go get you a place dude
you're 28 freaking years old
and you'll get out of debt you'll figure
it out people making eighty thousand
dollars pay off seventy three thousand
dollars all the time and they don't live
with their parents it works all the time
and you need to do that it's gonna be so
good for you and it's gonna be good for
your mom it's time she's ready for you
to leave
or your dad is or both of them are
um
they may be really ready for you to
leave i don't know but i don't know i
don't know it's just um
there's a developmental thing here that
is really good for you
and so yes it's going to slow down
mathematically your ability to get out
of debt as fast whoopty doopty and yes
making 80 000 a year you can find a
place in rhode island tuesday i think
you're going to be okay
you're going to make it but you need to
get out dude
so george
the producer james just handed us an
article
it's juicy it's a juicy one
well
okay
this pisses me off
all right because
the um
consumer financial protection bureau
brought to you by elizabeth warren
that's where it came from
was put in place to protect the consumer
they were put in charge of a piece of
legislation that's been in place for 30
or 40 years
called the federal fair debt collection
practices act there's federal law that
dictates how collectors have to behave
or they're in violation of federal law
when they're trying to collect from you
the consumer financial protection bureau
is in charge of the federal debt fair
debt collection practices act
regulations and uh fines and you know
you know basically protecting the
consumer
so what did they do
under this administration
decided to help out the collectors
instead of the consumer
so they just
new rules approved by the consumer
financial protection bureau
that took effect this is from npr that
took effect on tuesday dictate how
collection agencies can email or text
people as well as message them on social
media
to collect unpaid debts so now they can
hassle you on twitter
your facebook account
text you and email you where a part of
protection
at the bureau did they not get they just
unleash the hounds on the consumer
financial protection
bureau you need to read the title of the
place you work
good god i thought it was bad enough
when my mom joined facebook
and now the collectors are on there too
the whole gang
you can't stop everyone's watching you
george
you know a way to fix this is don't be
on facebook but yeah
good luck well it's easier now
everyone's going you know they're on
instagram
you have to have something like i've got
where i pay people to do this stuff
because i can't stand it but this is
what's crazy it says they can attempt to
join your network by sending you a
friend request and they must give you
the option to opt out of being contacted
online and any messages they send do
have to be private so they're not going
to go posting on your public page dave
don't worry
yeah that would be a violation of
privacy act a whole other act
the rules are really disappointing and
concerning in a number of ways says
april newhoff a staff attorney for the
national consumer law center hello april
that's an understatement
uh yeah disappointing no this is just
ridiculous this is what we in the south
call we just let the fox in the hen
house that's a good saying i like that
one
here's what's crazy chomp chomp we are
going to see
so much spam come out of this it says
allowing debt collectors to email text
and use social media to contact
consumers also gives criminals a new
avenue to try to swindle people out of
their money a practice canoe hoff
expects to increase in the future all
right i get a bunch of crap on my apple
phone updates
that i don't want
and they force it on me and i have to go
in and turn it off or turn it on and so
that people aren't watching me and all
this other bull crap all these things
they do with this technology i'm getting
just paranoid but they're gonna have to
put a thing on the apple phone
oh yeah block collector text
select
on or off
and that maybe you know there you go
that'll work
so um i did just somebody just showed me
the damn i'm so technology stu you're
gonna look at me because you know i'm
stupid but um
yeah you can turn off uh not the phone
doesn't ring if it's an unrecognized
numbers because the 73 000 calls i get a
year on my
warranty for my car that i need to buy
which is hilarious you're calling dave
ramsey's phone i mean come on but um
yeah i mean all those are blocked now
and so automatically they don't it
doesn't ring my phone so i can we're
going to have that selection for
collectors apple's going to have to
protect us because the protection bureau
won't protect us oh boy and you know the
weird thing about sliding into the dms
here on on your instagram account if the
only people sliding into the dms are the
collectors that's a sad life we got to
pay off this debt get rid of it leave
them on red
you can't ghost these people
they're going to be after you
[Music]
that sums it up
wow
the consumer financial protection
bureau
can't even live up to its title oxymoron
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
bye
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry
it's worth it
[Music]
so
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today
welcome to the ramsey show in the lobby
of ramsay solutions on the debt free
stage travis and betsy are with us hey
guys how are you great good how are you
very cool where do you all live
mom bellevue texas
near houston very cool well i mean we
have folks wear a lot of t-shirts on the
show and to do their debt-free screams
and so forth but it might be fairly easy
to guess that you're here to do a
debt-free screen because you have a paid
for
house whoop
whoops those shirts gave it away
you're weirdos huh yes wow i love it
very cool well the great shirts by the
way it's got a house with paid stamped
acrylic very simple those of you looking
deeply in your radio and can't see what
i'm talking about but yeah very cool so
how much have you paid off
144 000. very cool how long did this
take three and a half years good for you
and your range of income during that
time 150 to 170. very good and what do
y'all do for a living so i'm a chemical
engineer
and um i was a school counselor turned
stay-at-home mom oh very good very very
good so 144 000 what's this house worth
375 conservatively awesome very cool
very cool how much y'all got in
retirement
uh 950 or so baby steps there's that
there they are look at them look at you
guys you're double weirdos i love you
way to go how old are you millionaires
i'm 37 36.
touchdown
this is incredible start the way right
here get ready go ready go george here
we go all right here we go i did it
very good i love it guys congratulations
okay so uh the last three and a half
years you've been working on the house
tell us the whole story about your
journey and how you got ramsey-fied so
our journey with ramsay really uh
started back uh 14 years ago when i
graduated college so i i've been always
been told to invest in retirement once i
got a job but i didn't know how to do it
so i looked for books uh found total
money makeover and uh
uh from there
i i just did the investing advice so uh
oh so dave ramsey's investing in vice
made him a millionaire
oh oh well unfortunately yes yeah i
think that was legitimately yeah i
thought i thought that i thought he was
a boomer i thought you were a fraud dave
i'm i'm a grifter
[Music]
that's a great name a grifter strong
just strong it's amazing how this works
way to go you guys guys have debt like
consumer debt
so
the the rest of the story is so fast
forward 10 years so our church started a
financial peace momentum campaign back
in 2017
and so
they started advertising that i i saw
that as a way i'm remembering uh total
money makeover i saw that away is uh
getting us on the same page because i
had been doing most of the financial
stuff for our household and i just
wanted to set us up for a better future
so
we got we started on it in january 2018
and just
it's been off uh to the races ever since
all right so betsy he says we're going
to this financial class at church and
you said what
uh
we're a good team so there was no
convincing we just went and okay sure
i'll go go mm-hmm well you're sweet
she she works well with me okay and so
you went to the class and uh did you
what did you think did you think it was
gonna be boring or crazy or what was
your preconceived notion and then what
was it really like
well i should have known when i met
travis he was reading the total money
makeover so it wasn't
dave is not a you're not a new concept
to me um it was pretty much what i
thought
um it was good to learn together to do
the class together okay cool cool
and it sets it up and during this
process you made the decision to come
home be a full-time mom
when um i had spence you know six okay
perfect very good about a year or so
before okay very good way to go you guys
wow
how does it feel to be a hundred percent
debt free
and have a net worth over a million
dollars
it's a bit surreal i i don't know that
we've been debt-free for a couple of
months now but
um and this is our first vacation to
tennessee so this is a big vacation for
us just enjoying being debt-free and
yeah uh
enjoying family time that's that's what
we wanted to do so what's your big thing
you want to do now that you're out
so
travel yeah travel yeah i mean that's
our why trying to create memories with
our young kids so traveling all kinds of
fun places getting them to experience
all kinds of different things
very cool that's worth it yeah we've had
some wonderful trips ramsay spent some
money on experience man i tell you we do
we'll do it more than we will anything
else and so um really that's a good
that's a good spin for the dollar way to
go guys
very very cool all right you've been
doing this a long time you got this
thing dialed in both of you been through
financial peace university you've hit
you've touched every base
baby step seven baby steps millionaires
people ask
how did you do that what do you tell
them the key to getting here is
i would say that the key is just to live
be okay with living below your means
people have boats and huge pools and
cars and
car payments and
all kind of stuff that they have to pay
for and um just we don't go out to eat
that much and we have a garden and we
eat out of our garden and
we've just lived below our means and
made a plan and stuck to it
yeah
for me i'm the nerd so the every dollar
app was
really key when we started it in 2018 it
made uh budgeting fun you know it seems
seems kind of weird but that was uh what
did it for me yeah that's a big deal an
engineer who likes budgeting go figure
who's amazing would have thunk it that's
incredible he would project the every
dollar app on the tv and i told him
because i've listened to many hours of
the show i've got 17 minutes
17 minutes so he took over the netflix
watching and he said no we're streaming
the budget baby
nothing says romance like a budget
streaming to the tv that's fun way to go
this is great yeah fun fun fun fun who
are your biggest cheerleaders outside
the two of you
uh so our our uh
our parents are very uh helpful in this
just uh cheering us on and they came
along with you yeah yeah that's uh
betsy's parents okay
all right you raised millionaires that's
pretty cool
not bad
kids that turn out that's incredible
this is good i like character turnout
yeah every parent's dream this is
awesome yeah do the kids have t-shirts
on two that match yes uh different
slightly different let's get them up
here what are their names and ages uh so
you got spence he's six
and hattie she's four okay
uh
keep uh keep pinsley's weird and we own
it hashtag we own it
she already knows what the hashtag is
i'm very impressed
of course she does
yeah she can fix your iphone george i'm
just saying all right way to go you guys
hey we got an advanced copy of baby
steps millionaires for you to celebrate
the fact that you is
way to go it comes out january the 11th
but we're gonna give you a copy today
and a copy of the total money makeover
as well and you'll have that to give
away so very very cool stuff all right
it's travis betsy spence and hattie from
houston texas 144 000
paid off in three and a half years house
and everything with their retirement
baby steps millionaires making 150 to
170 in their 30s count it down let's
hear a debt free scream
three
two one
[Music]
[Applause]
touchdown
oh man get on financial peace university
get on the same page push through do the
baby steps i mean this stuff
it's getting boring
in the best way so it's just so
predictable yeah and this is not a plug
for your book baby steps millionaires
but it's amazing how many people just
follow the plan and they go oh my gosh
we're millionaires and it's almost like
accidental but it's not accidental
because they here's the thing we find it
all the time and their numbers matched
it too with the study we did that we
first revealed in chris hogan's book
everyday millionaires and we put the
whole study in the back of the baby
steps millionaires just for you to read
by the way it's the largest study of
millionaires ever done we find typically
the paid for houses about a third of the
net worth and the other two thirds is
their big retirement plan and they put
money in mutual funds and it's just not
rocket science people
is a millionaire a billionaire nope
a lot of difference
billions a thousand million
a lot of difference but a million
most people got and you can do it and
it's doable
and you can retire with dignity and you
can travel and change your family tree
and
pretty stinking cool
this is the ramsay show
um
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five
five two two five john is with us in
boise idaho hi john welcome to the
ramsay show
thank you sir for having me on sure
what's up um
so my question is
uh i'm working right now um but i'm also
in flight school trying to cash flow
going through uh helicopter flight
school good for you and anyways
um my question is
at what point um with it working a job
when the java gets so dysfunctional
amongst your co-workers
uh is it right to just quit and try to
find another job
um
because i work in direct sales i work
for a roofing company i'm good at my job
my bosses appreciate what i do but
trying to uh all i do is set up uh
inspections for
uh project managers to get on uh wind
damage for folks so you know we do free
inspections and uh
the goal is you know if we can help them
out with uh the roof get see if we can
get their paid forth or insurance if
they have you know enough wind damage on
the roof anyways all i do is drive
around and talk to folks
and
it's getting really
my bosses are great my co-workers are
not and i'm just like trying to figure
out
how to balance i guess flight school
or or and getting in a different job
possibly
how old are you
23.
and you said you're you're on the road
talking with clients most of the time
how much interaction do you have with
these coworkers
um it depends on the day so um we have a
daily sales meeting and then
um you know a lot of tech full of phone
calls sometimes you see them during the
day i i have the option to ride with
them
uh like drive you know with one project
manager and just roll around with him
for the day
or i can just drive around myself
talking to different customers so i've
chosen for most of my job to just drive
around myself because i think it's a
better use of time um you can talk to
more people that way than having two
guys running around in one vehicle
so um but
how long you've been doing this
uh this job i just started in september
i've been doing sales for a couple years
what do you make
so wait a minute stop stop saying
okay all right yeah we'll go ahead and
what do you make that's good what do you
make
uh right now i make
uh it's 100 commission base uh i make
about 23 to 25 2500 a month
okay
all right well number one nothing
nothing wrong with looking for another
job and getting a different job
okay yeah
however there may be something here for
you to learn
it's maybe a learning opportunity
and sometimes in our 20s uh god puts us
in a place where we're learning
and it could be that you learn to
interact with your supervisors and
explain to them your leaders which you
seem to like
after four whole months
or three whole months um
and you know maybe there's some uh
behaviors that they can work on
uh for you meaning these people need to
learn to behave what are they doing
that's so toxic
well
the biggest thing is
i would say i set an appointment i set
up you know i set a time say like two
o'clock for an inspection and
consistently um
my guy my project managers either can't
make it cancel it reschedule whatever
and they just and they end up losing the
job because of it
and that happens
very very often well that's a broken
business model
that's not bad people there's something
else going on
they're either lazy they're not
shouldn't be doing the job or they've
got the system set up to where you
should have set hours that you can book
somebody and then they show up the
company's losing money because of this
not just you
well yeah i would agree like so your
frustration is not what i would take to
your leader
i would take to your leader that the
customer is frustrated and we're losing
sales i think we're losing you know half
of the sales that we shouldn't be losing
we should be doubling our sales if they
just showed up on time so what we need
boss is a system
that that uh when i book an appointment
that the guy actually shows now how can
we put that together i'd be happy to
help show me what to do
and it might be you can help them solve
this problem
that yeah that that could be an option i
might have talked to my bosses about it
my bosses like i said my bosses are
awesome i have no grip they're not
awesome they're watching a stupid thing
happen right in front of them
gotcha i'm awesome i would have kicked
somebody's butt by now and fixed this
that's called owning and running a
company okay so
you know yeah i mean they may be nice
guys but this is inefficient frustrating
for you frustrating for the customer
because either you are
booking times you shouldn't be booking
because you don't have a blocked out
time for your people to go in or
something else is going on if you want
to go to flight school that's fine if
you want to change jobs that's fine but
dude you've been there for three months
and you are 23.
so you know
take a chill pill and work on this a
little bit and see if you can't help
them fix it if you can't help them fix
it eject but if every time you have a
little bit of a rough spot you eject
you're all you're going to do is be in
the air from ejecting all the time
you're just going to be flying all the
time
going to flight school so
yeah there we go yeah right in the
helicopter yeah okay got him but uh yeah
and besides that unless there are a few
helicopter jobs that make good money but
not tons of them
um it sounds like he doesn't want to be
in sales long term but right now he
needs to focus on getting enough income
so that he can save up and pay cash for
flight school and he's not making great
money it's 100 commission he's bringing
in 2 300 a month 30 probably 30 000
bucks a year there's better sales jobs
out there 100 percent commission if he
can do it if
he'd be making 60 so he's losing half
the sales to this stupid system so i
don't know but uh um you know yes you
should look for a job if you can't get
this fixed
and um yes you should cash flow flight
school and it's going to take you some
time and yes you need to consider what
you are paying to become a helicopter
pilot versus what that job pays
because it's not big money in most cases
you know private jet pilot makes good
money
uh helicopter pilot not so much
there's a few cases they do a few
situations they do but most of those are
probably taken by somebody with a lot of
experience and
you know you're running a copter in in
you know a different situation but
it's an okay career to get into and but
it's got a long
climb no pun intended
open phones at
825-5225
maggie is in san diego hi maggie welcome
to the ramsay show
hi thank you for taking my call
so basically basically i own a house i
moved
in with my aunt to help take care of her
um in the later months of her life
and she's put my name on the trust for
her house so my question is should i
sell my house because i'm in california
the housing market is white hot and i
can make a lot of money on the equity
and pay off her house
or should i just really focus on paying
off her house while i rent out my house
and let the renters pay that off for me
what is her life expectancy
um
i would say no more than a year she's on
hospice so
um it's not that much longer but
yeah i wouldn't pay off anybody's house
that was not in my name
so when
she passes this you can pay off your
house her what becomes your house at
that point
um and it's left to you in a trust via a
will correct
um it's as far as i know it's just a
simple trust i don't think it was a
full-on will because we just started
doing it when i moved in with her and
we're just finalizing let me help you
with a piece of real estate this
expensive as far as i know doesn't cut
it
okay you got to get in there no
and you need to sit down with an
attorney and verify that this thing is
going to you
and exactly the vehicle has been put in
place to exactly execute that because
this is coming at you really fast
and um you know if you guys have butt
did this paperwork you got a real
problem so you need to fix that now
while she's alive and able to do it and
so get in there and really know the
details of exactly how this property is
going to transfer to you if you want to
go and sell your house now that's fine
just put the money in the bank and then
when she passes you pay off the new
house that becomes your house was her
house because you did this paperwork
perfectly
with great detail and great diligence
otherwise you'll become one of those
nightmare stories that calls me here and
don't do that
good hour george good times well done
well done good job ben and kelly in the
booth i am dave ramsey your host we'll
be back
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show did you know the ramsay show
is one of the most popular podcasts in
the world
subscribe or follow today wherever you
listen to podcast
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice george campbell ramsey
personality is my co-host today as we
answer your questions about your life
and your money triple eight eight two
five five two two five is the number
sherry is in kansas city hi sherry
welcome to the ramsay show
hi there thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
i have a 22 year old son who was in an
apprentice program getting paid so no
college debt but and he's going to be
finishing that program in about a year
looking ahead and he's working or he
would be the one calling you i'm looking
ahead he's wanting to know
what you suggest and how he builds
credit because right now he has
none because he he hasn't purchased
anything
he's purchased something he just didn't
use debt
that's correct he's always paid cash
and he asked you to ask us
did he come to you wondering about this
he did because we've
he's grown up with with um dave ramsey
and and knowing the knowledge behind it
because his parents we live by it so
well what are your thoughts on how to
build credit or if it's wise too
well i don't know that's why i called
you because we didn't start using dave
ramsey until we were almost 30 years old
and going by his plan so by that time
we'd already established credit through
purchasing a house and um a credit card
um
i'm confused which dave ramsey you've
been following
because this dave ramsey never told you
to build your fico score or build credit
we told you to get out of that and stay
out of debt does that sound familiar
yes correct i'm saying that we were at
that point and then we met you yeah no
but you said your son grew up with dave
ramsey and his first question is how to
build credit but so he must have missed
something
well other than knowing to just save and
that's what he's doing
um
but we don't know
i mean
okay
he'll be fighting for a long time sure
and so we just wanted to know
our recommendations so the way i was
raised at 22 i thought the same thing
and i was like i got to build my score
that's that's how you live your
financial life and what we found is that
the best way to build the financial
future for your son is without a credit
score at all and that's very counter
cultural that's very against the grain
but he's already done it by paying cash
for school and so the question is you
only need
does he need a credit score if he's not
going to take out any more debt and
that's the only reason why people really
build their credit score is so that they
can have a high score so that they can
take on more debt and so if he's already
on board with the ramsey plan of living
his life without debt then he can do all
of the things that everyone else can do
and he can do it without a credit score
and that includes he's going to pay cash
for a car therefore he doesn't need a
credit score because he doesn't need a
car loan he can do manual underwriting
when it comes time for him to buy a
house which means they're not going to
look at his credit score they're going
to look at his overall financial picture
and you can get a mortgage without a
credit score
and so really everything else you're
paying cash for and so you don't need a
credit score the purpose of the credit
score is to get you in debt so that you
can get more in debt so that you can get
more in debt and you need to build up
your score
precisely out of the 10 000 millionaires
that we surveyed and asked them how they
became a millionaire the number that
said
that they became millionaires because of
their great credit or great credit score
was precisely zero
and so building the credit score is not
a goal that we would teach you
we would teach you to avoid debt pay
cash for things
and um
you know if you're going to get a
mortgage it's the only time we don't
yell at you for debt uh because it
because all the other debtors are
prohibiting you from winning and really
the mortgage is too but at least you can
get it paid off at least it's going up
in value
and so um you know that's the one thing
but other than that so the answer is i
would not build my credit score i would
not worship at the altar of the great
fico it turns out he is not a very good
provider as a god
that's for sure yeah and sherry i've got
a resource for you if you go look up the
fine print podcast you can go to
fineprintpodcast.com
let your son listen to the episode that
we did titled the dirty truth behind
your credit score we dig into this it's
short it's enjoyable he'll have a great
time
and it will unpack why we say you don't
need a credit score and we'll show him
how to do all of those things and it's
by george and so it's a lot nicer than
me
and so you're gonna like it
he'll enjoy it thank you for admitting
that i'm nicer than you well it's not a
heart attack america has been waiting
for this most people are nicer than me
um i'm actually really nice because i'm
really telling you what you need to go
win because i love you but i just uh it
hurts to hear a little i don't really
put much
icing on it
so it's just the cake okay so
but um and i'm kind of in a hurry
because there's a lot of people that
need this help so that that's just makes
me get to the point
in 30 years of doing this it's just you
know okay there you go that's what you
need to do and so there it is and yeah
yeah but so yeah go listen to the fine
print by the way all the episodes the
fine print was robin hood but the last
one of the last last one yeah the last
scene of the first season and now we're
going to do another season and we've got
it now we're thinking maybe uh time
share episode oh yeah reverse mortgages
conversion mortgage episodes oh scams we
we got to do scam scams there's so many
i mean for real scams we talk about a
lot of things that are the same as a
scam but like real people they get
scammed and real scams artists out there
those are that's a really good episode
that'll be good we chose a podcast where
there's endless amounts of content so
that's good there's always ways people
are getting screwed when it comes to
money that's true that's true so the
fine print one of the ramsey network
well the ramsey network's newest podcast
and very popular by the way
it's done really well george i
appreciate that well thanks for all of
you who listen out there jason is in
lansing michigan hi jason how are you
hey dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up and same here uh hey
my question is um about some student
loans that my wife has
basically she's got about 23 000 uh
student loans to pay off um and then the
zero percent interest rate ends and the
payments seem to begin at the beginning
or at the end of january
uh she's been working her tail off while
doing her master's classes
and she's got enough to pay out off
right now good do it and i guess my
question is should you pay it all off
now and and end up paying no interest
and all that yes or or wait until maybe
good old joe implements one of those
forgiveness plans that i've been hearing
so much about you're gonna be dead
before that happens
okay
yeah i mean he may get around to it but
if you wait on washington to be your
blessing
your life's gonna suck
i believe that i i don't support the the
government they off by any means but you
know i'm not an idiot either and unless
it comes to you i pay this off and then
february comes by and they say oh here's
ten thousand dollars off of your loans
that's not going to happen well it's
it's not complicated it's not coming in
february okay
there's a saying
you know old people used to say
older than me even like if something's
really difficult they go well it takes
an act to congress meaning it's going to
take forever
well guess what in order to forgive
student loans it takes literally an act
of congress
which means it takes forever
that island of misfit toys can't get
anything done up there
even if it was the right thing to do
they can't get it done and this ain't
the right thing to do take control yeah
dude you got the money write the check
be done with it move on with your life
say thank you i got an education thank
you i'm debt free now let's get on with
making some money being outrageously
generous and helping other people with
it that's the plan don't wait on
washington to bless your life your life
will suck
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free
shipping with blinds.com there's no need
to renovate your entire home just change
out what's on your windows with upscale
choices like faux wood blinds cellular
and roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
[Applause]
well with all the high-tech real estate
apps and home browsing sites available
you might think no one needs a real
estate agent to buy a house these days
that's very wrong
in fact 90 of buyers who bought a home
last year used a real estate
professional why would they do that well
if you've got an experienced agent a
dedicated agent it's their number one
job to help you win hey it's a wild
world out there it is a crazy market
this is not amateur hour this market's
wild
house prices go up you get in bidding
wars a top agent is an expert negotiator
who knows what it takes to make a
winning offer plus the seller almost
always covers the commission for the
buyer's agent anyway
meaning you get all the benefits of an
agent for free i mean
what's there to lose by using an expert
nothing so if you're going to list the
house for sale you don't list it right
now by yourself you get a pro in your
corner if you're going to buy a house
right now you get a pro in your corner
check out our nationwide network of the
best performing real estate agents in
your area they're called endorsed local
providers because we endorse them
they're local and they provide you with
help they're elps
these real estate agents are ramsey
trusted they're committed to putting
your values first
and they are at the top of their local
market
com slash agent to find a trusted ramsay
trusted pro who can help you buy a home
ramsey solutions dot com slash
agent
brandon's with us in oklahoma city hey
brandon welcome to the ramsey show hey
dave thanks for having me sure what's up
um so i'm a truck driver and i make
about 45 000 a year gross i had
17 000 saved but i spent most of that
money on getting my cdl and i financed
it originally come across your show and
it was stay out of debt so i said you
know what i'll go ahead and pay it off
so now i've got 8 000 saved
and um
driving a truck i'm able to put back a
thousand a month currently
so i i don't know how much a person
needs as a safety fund or really how
much i i remember seeing something about
25 of your of your um
your monthly maybe your take home being
your mortgage i'm still a little
confused on that and how do i know
when i'm able to buy a home and how much
should i have saved more or less
so if you're following the baby steps
baby step one is to have a thousand
dollars saved you have that baby step
two is to pay off all of your consumer
debt you've got that all paid off
no debt yep yep no debt so baby step
three is where we save our three to six
months of expenses so what does one
month of expenses for you look like
right now
uh 850. 850. okay great so i would set
aside maybe that looks like five or
seven eight grand for you
for a fully funded emergency fund and
beyond that the rest of that money can
go to 3b which is where we're going to
save up for a down payment on a house so
what i would be doing if i were you is
looking at homes in my area that i would
want to buy and the parameters are
pretty easy we have a great mortgage
calculator on our website that can help
walk you through this but what you're
looking for is to have 10 or 20 percent
down i love 20 or more because it helps
you avoid something called pmi private
mortgage insurance and all it does is
protect the bank in case you can't pay
so if you can get 20 down and then have
the payment on that mortgage on a
15-year fixed rate mortgage be no more
than a quarter of your take-home pay
that's going to allow you to have the
margin to continue on with the baby
steps and pay off your house early so
there's a lot of numbers in there but
the key is to make sure that you've got
that down payment saved and i don't know
what the houses are running for in your
area have you done any research on that
oh yeah so in my area i found a little
um i'm saying also for me i can get away
with a small home i've seen them go for
anywhere from forty to sixty thousand on
a nice little um one bedroom one bath
home nice okay that's fantastic
okay so if you save 10 grand for an
emergency fund you leave that alone
that's your rainy day fund
all right
and then beyond that you start saving
your down payment
and um you know if you save up 15 or 20
grand and put that down on a 60 or 70
thousand dollar house you're gonna be
just fine
okay
now on a house or a mortgage that cheap
you're probably not going to be going to
a traditional mortgage company you're
probably just going to be talking to
your credit union because basically
you're taking out what for some people
as a car loan
okay the regular mortgage companies
won't do a little mortgage like this a
tiny one like this so most the time
anyway if they do they charge you too
much so your local credit union your
local bank is the easiest the best way
the most efficient way to get a smallish
loan like that which the beauty of that
is then you can turn around and just pay
it off just keep chunking money on it
and you'll have it paid off in no time
and that'll be a very cool place to be
have a paid off house no debt of any
kind and an emergency fund wow very good
good plan
kelly our kenny is with us rather kenny
is in savannah georgia hi kenny how are
you hello dave thank you guys for taking
my call sure what's up
so i have um so i recently came across
your show about last month and it really
motivated me to pay off my debt i was
young dumb and stupid in the military
and i accumulated a lot of credit card
cut and i also financed the car which is
another stupid decision i made
um
but i kind of followed your debt
avalanche message
about three weeks ago and i paid off
uh 5 000 towards my credit card so now i
only have 16 000
left overall that for myself my wife is
different she's a student right now
she's about to graduate with her degree
so i just want to know what's the best
way to tackle that should i keep
following the avalanche or just do with
that snowball
i already have an emergency uh fund in
place already the baby step one gotcha
okay well at ramsey we don't teach the
avalanche we teach the debt snowball
okay okay and that's listing your debts
smallest to largest
paying minimum payments on everything
but the little one and attack the little
one we also teach you that there are
that when you are married we are one the
preacher said and now you are one he
didn't say now you are a joint venture
so how much wife does your how much debt
does your wife have
so the the only debt that she has is the
school which is 19 000. okay so thousand
i encourage
and then you end
here for her masters to do uh a federal
workforce that way the school paper
on that as she works for the school so
that's what she'll be doing and what
will she be making at the
school uh she will be a teacher and it
will be about
um
1500 a month okay and what do you make
i make uh 52. good for you um a year a
year all right so you got about a 70 to
an 80 000 household income depending on
how many hours you all work and you've
got 34 000 in debt between the two of
you does that sound about right
yes sir
so what we're going to do here is do you
guys have any savings right now
any money myself i'm the uh uh just
myself i have about uh almost four
thousand in the bank
okay so if you're following the baby
you're married so that's hers too
yes yes sir all right and you guys have
one joint bank account
uh no we do not ours is separate but our
savings uh create savings for both of us
to have together
okay well i'll tell you this if you guys
want to feel the progress of this thing
you're going to have to get on the same
page get one bank account get the goal
get the plan and do this thing together
okay because right now it sounds like
you're living two different lives
financially
okay but what you're gonna do is have
that thousand dollars for your starter
emergency fund and everything else is
gonna go towards the debt
and you're gonna do the debt snowball
like dave mentioned list them all
smallest to largest and then once you're
out of consumer debt you're done with
that 34 000 we go back and we fully fund
that emergency fund with three to six
months of expenses that's going to
create this financial foundation for you
guys to where you don't have money
stress anymore so kenny what i'll do is
i'll put you on hold kelly will pick up
we're gonna send you a copy of the book
the total money makeover to show you
exactly how to do this combine your
finances
focus exclusively on the debt listing
your debts smallest balance to largest
balance that's the debt snowball you pay
minimum payments on everything but the
little one you attack the little one
with a vengeance as fast as you can no
eating out
no going on vacation
no frills beans and rice rice and beans
scorched earth syndrome around the house
there no lifestyle we're getting out of
debt how fast can we get out of debt
making 70 to 80 000 owing 34. probably
gonna take you about 18 months if you're
really really intense
and the more intense you are by the way
the faster you'll get out because the
deeper you'll sacrifice
hang on kelly will pick up we're going
to send you a copy of the total money
makeover
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today kyle is with us he's in
des moines
iowa it says on my screen you're
debt-free kyle congratulations
thank you well done how much have you
paid off
i paid off sixty three thousand three
hundred and fifty nine dollars did you
say 63 or 53
63 63 what
63 359
okay 359 dollars good and how long did
it take you to pay this off
just so it under four months good for
you wow and your range of income during
that time
so kind of crazy i actually went from
unemployed to finishing this year
grossing 150 000. cool what do you do
for a living
i am a full-time photographer and
videographer so i do a lot of weddings
and family photos sports commercial work
you name it i kind of do it all so you
just started your own business and it
took off
correct yep so i lost my job
so a little back story so i actually
went through a divorce 16 months ago
and then
i'm not even a month later on my
birthday i actually got laid off due to
covet oh my gosh
so i had a camera
and i kind of just started hustling um
started shooting weddings photos like i
said um family photos anything to just
keep a roof over my head
and
with my finances it got a little
scary um i had literally like less than
a thousand dollars to my name and i just
started this business um and really
covet allowed me to
run with this opportunity that i had wow
wow good for you man i mean you really
you got after it that's impressive what
kind of debt was the 63 000
so 58 000 was student loans and then
5300 was my car loan
okay so that's what that was your part
of the divorce you walked out with those
things
yeah well yeah the student loans was
mine um and then my car as well i owned
on my own okay all right and so you got
to knock it out so what made you decide
in the middle of all these crisis is
hitting you at one time that you're
going to get out of debt
when my back was against the wall it
really
it was an eye-opening moment for me that
i really had no
big picture with my finances i had never
really added up all my debt
so when i did that it was really a shock
to me i didn't realize that i had over
63 thousand dollars in debt
so i started getting very intentional
with my finances
and since i was self-employed
i had to refinance to keep the home that
i was living in after the divorce
so i had to get a full-time job in the
meantime so that allowed me to pay off
my debt extremely fast because i was
working a full-time job living off that
income
and then every wedding every photo shoot
was getting thrown at my debt
oh wow okay so even after you got laid
off you went back and got a full time
correct yep because i needed to
refinance my house um
after the divorce okay wow that's
incredible man you're resilient
thank you yeah i stayed really
optimistic that the whole thing and you
know i
once i started my desk job eight months
ago
i listened to you guys every day
and listened to other people's debt-free
screams and it really kept me motivated
knowing that that was just going to be a
short spin in my life that i had to
buckle down
at that time and pay off my debt and i
kind of
set a goal to pay it off in six months
because my birthday was the date that
the student loans were supposed to start
back up with the interest happy birthday
right it was an amazing success from
sally may
yep so by my by my birthday i had all my
debt paid off and 20 000 emergency fund
fully in place wow yeah you went rice
and beans gazelle intense how did you
like tactically pay that much in that
short amount of time 63k in four months
is incredible did you just have fun
great cash flow
yes great cash flow and i knew how many
weddings i had coming up and that's what
really made me look at it six months
before my birthday and six months before
the student loans were gonna start back
up
i knew i could do it just doing the math
with
how many weddings i had lined up and
photo shoots and etc while i was working
my full-time desk job as well just
living off that income yeah you just
made a chunk in a short period of time
yep and i knew it was a short stint and
now it's quickly flipping in the other
direction you know as quickly as i paid
it off now i'm starting to invest with
the smart investor pro and got a fully
funded emergency fund and it's just
quickly going in the other direction as
well hey man way to go
you're going to be a baby steps
millionaire in 20 minutes the way you're
going well done how old are you thank
you i am 27.
well done fantastic great great job man
great job so proud of that thank you so
what do you tell people the key to
getting out of dead ass
so i was a nerd through the whole thing
so i know budget is a
a big a big one for most and it
definitely is for me too but i would say
find something that you love to do
and that you're passionate about and
find a way to monetize it because i
think if you're really passionate about
something it will show in your work and
you'll make money doing what you love
and it won't feel like work
there you go where's christine ken when
you need him yeah incredible man
absolutely beautifully said yeah that's
that was
ken coleman home run right there i like
it thank you so well done sir very very
well done who were your biggest
cheerleaders
my family was very supportive
and now i am with a
girlfriend and she has been amazing and
so supportive through this whole journey
for me too so it's helped a help a lot
they're definitely very important to me
i mean you had to have some people in
your corner you lost a marriage and you
lost your job yeah
and then you know and then you hit kova
head on
and and and you got 63 000 piled up in
the corner over here getting ready to
come down on your head on your birthday
you know and so yeah you had to have
some people in your corner pushing you
and saying you can do this
definitely my family's super support
over super close
and i knew
that this
listening to you guys and thinking more
long term you know obviously it was bad
at the time but i was thinking more long
term like i do want to change my family
tree
um
that i'm thinking more into the future
long term and definitely had support
system with my family yeah well you're
definitely gonna get there you're
definitely gonna get there so very well
done you guys man i'm so proud of you
we've got a copy of the total money
makeover for you to give away and
encourage someone else and an advanced
copy of the new book baby steps
millionaires of mine which comes out in
uh january but we're going to send you a
copy early to celebrate the fact that
you are a debt free and on your way to
being a baby steps millionaire that's
the next step for you so well done kyle
proud of you man you're a hero
thank you so much good job good job all
right kyle in des moines iowa 63 000
paid off in four months making zero to
150 that's a story count it down let's
hear a debt free scream
three two one i'm debt-free
[Applause]
man oh man oh man nothing's gonna stop
that guy
you know i was just thinking that's very
interesting because a lot of people
uh he turned every one of those uh
lemons into lemonade i mean in every
case he he flipped it in his language
and you could tell it flipped in his
head
and he flipped his language to where
he's saying okay i went through this
horrible thing but that means i get to
do this and this happened but that means
i get to do this
instead of like well i lost my job
and eeyore is my spirit animal and
oh it's bad
it's gonna be bad oh and then covet hit
and
i just can't get ahead
i sure hope biden will send me more
money
you know he wasn't sitting around saying
that no there was no wallowing it was
just like all right i got punched in the
face i'm gonna get back up and i'm gonna
make something out of this
and he did i mean he lined up serious
numbers of jobs right there in a very
short period of time made enough money
to clear the whole thing in four months
that's
i mean he's stacked and double stacked
yeah but uh but you know all of it was
just oh okay well
well my heart is broken and i'm going
through this horrible thing called a
divorce and while this is happening and
while that's happening
i'm just gonna take all these lemons and
make lemonade and just get out and and
his whole life is set up
but that's a
all of that was just a decision it was a
way of
viewing this through a positive
opportunistic lens
rather than viewing it through
i've been slapped and i can't do
anything lens i mean yeah and i guess
you know sometimes people do that kind
of in their nature
but sometimes that's just a decision i'm
just really gonna choose
abundance rather than scarcity he had a
lot of excuses to just let this let
these loans sit wait for forgiveness
exactly most people listening they
weren't going through stuff like that
and they they can make the choice today
just go you know i'm going to be a kyle
nothing's going to stop me this that's
going to be out of my life
[Music]
absolutely very cool very well done good
job kyle great work brother
this
is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
john 13 35 by this everyone will know
that you are my disciples
if you love one another
[Music]
charles schwab said the way to develop
the best that is in a person is by
appreciation and encouragement
that's true
and that's good open phones this hour
george camel ramsey personality is my
co-host
and daniel is in maui hawaii hi daniel
how are you
hey how's it going better than i deserve
sir what's up
hey so um
i'm the escrow right now i'm trying to
buy this condo
um
and uh the guy wants fifty thousand over
the praise value
and uh the market right now everything's
really high and buying property here on
maui everybody's overpaying so i was
wondering like do you think
uh is that a good idea
what's the price of the condo
um
the guy wants 550 for it he got
appraised for 500 000.
how old is the appraisal
uh it just got appraised um
like a week ago
okay
just your first home purchase
it is how old are you
i'm 29 okay and how much down payment do
you have
went down twenty percent
so you have a hundred and some odd
thousand dollars to put down
yeah
where'd you get that
oh just just working and then i do a
little investing here and there
buying stocks from phone socks
okay and what do you make a year
uh currently
anywhere from 200 to 220.
okay what are you doing what do you do
for a living
i'm a journeyman lineman uh
build and repair power lines okay
all right
well is there any other condos available
that are not over market
um sounds like you stumbled onto one
deal and you fixated on this one deal
well because the all the other condos
around here on maui if it's next to a
beach it's it's in somewhere around
minimum like 650 you know so i found one
more inland and uh
so for 500 we offered 576
you know because his asking price was
550 and the appraisal came back way
lower
and uh just just for a three bedroom two
bath here it's so expensive and uh
so i thought it was the best deal you
know that i could find
but still 50 000 over appraisal you know
um
[Music]
so you're under contract on it and the
only question is whether you need to
walk away based on the low appraisal
we put a clause in there saying we'd
only pay 25 000 over the appraisal and
uh but he's the guy's not budging he
just wants to stick 550.
okay so time to run tell him to order
another appraisal at his expense and get
one for five and a quarter then
yeah
yeah
you could do that
there are closing dates coming up uh
on the
27th
so
and right now i'm getting appraisers uh
it takes a minute
i mean if i'm in your shoes
i'm saying hey it's five it's 5 25 or
we're gonna walk
because right now it feels like he's
trying to
throw you guys around a little bit and
make a little extra on the deal but
truthfully if you guys waited a little
longer saved up a little more you could
get something for 550 or 600 that's by
the beach so i'm not taking this deal as
is
either way
if i'm you
yeah
here's the thing you want to avoid
daniel and you're not avoiding it so i'm
that's why i'm saying it you want to
avoid the sense that you are uh that
you've gotten locked into the tractor
beam and you're being pulled into this
deal against your will like
you know and it's like like it's it has
to happen and there's nothing else and
it's the only way it'll do it and the
guy won't budge and we can't do it by
the 27th and
[Music]
you know it's all pulling you straight
into the deal and and all the while
you've got this sense that something's
wrong
and that's what we're hearing when we're
talking to you
the the way you're using your words the
way you're structuring your sentences
all of that is like i feel like i'm
like i'm trapped and i have to move
forward in this thing and it's not what
i want to do it doesn't feel right
and every time i do that
uh every time i talk myself into feeling
like i'm trapped and i go do something
that i know down in my gut is stupid uh
it kills me and uh you know you don't
feel good about this
i can tell by the way you're talking it
through but yet you feel trapped
and you're not trapped
it's just a stupid condo
there's a whole bunch of them on maui
i've been there lots of stupid condos on
maui now you may not get one for a while
it may be three or four more months it
may be something else but later on when
you get the right deal that you don't
have this weird feeling in your stomach
about because that's why you're asking
the question is because you don't feel
good about it
and i've got a friend daniel who's gave
me a rule in business a long long time
ago
he said when in doubt
don't
pretty good simple
i love it i wouldn't buy it daniel tell
the old boy
five and a quarter i made a deal with
you i will honor my word i will honor my
contract and we will close on the 17th
at 25 000 over appraisal sorry your
condo didn't appraise
i was willing to pay more but i was only
willing to pay 25 over appraisal and i'm
still willing to do that if you'd like
to sell your condo it is sold bubba but
if you don't want to sell it i
understand and we'll keep looking your
choice i'll give you odds he's going to
close
i'm with george
no i'm not taking the deal
not at me not at a dime over five and a
quarter unless another appraisal comes
in and i'm contractually bound to take
25 000 over appraisal at that point you
made a nice offer on that
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five jesse is in san
antonio hey jesse welcome to the ramsey
show
hi dave hey um
george my pleasure to talking to you
guys thank you for getting my call sure
my question is dave um
my question is should we should both my
wife and i fix the broken transmission
from the camera drive a little back
story i started your plan on june
of this year
and uh
we lost them
uh oh okay here's your rule of thumb
you add you look at what the
transmission costs
and or the repair on the car
and you ask yourself okay if i sell it
as is with a broken transmission because
he's driving a hooptie
and uh and so if the problem is the
transmission may cost more than the
hoopty
and so you know you don't put a 2 000
transmission in a 1 000 car
you don't put a 2000 transmission in a 3
000 car because it doesn't increase its
value you could put a used transmission
out of the junkyard in there uh and you
do that for a few hundred bucks or
something you can find some way to pull
that off that's fine but if you're
driving a two thousand dollar car that
has a one thousand dollar repair very
seldom are you gonna wanna do that you
just sell it as is you take that money
any other money you can scrape together
that you were gonna spend on the
transmission and you buy a little bit
better hoopty that doesn't need a
transmission and and you you keep moving
you keep rolling no payments no debt
yeah and that's you know that's part of
baby step two is you're sacrificing
you're driving the car you don't wanna
drive so that later you can drive the
car that you wanna drive and you can
upgrade over time and then you can
upgrade that car over time but
definitely don't go out saying well we
need a ten thousand dollar car now dave
because we need something reliable
because the last one crapped out on us
so we're not gonna buy another three
thousand dollar car that's what happens
you start to make stupid decisions
people over ramsey are unrealistic it's
unrealistic to remain broke your whole
life because you keep falling into the
debt trap yeah you have to live like no
one else so that later you can live
and give
like no one else george is right drive
like no one else so later you can drive
like no one else that's good advice
thank you i got it from you
i know a guy
i know a guy well i mean the truth is it
works and the problem is when you're in
the middle of where he is right now
it's a pain yeah
it's it's just you just get frustrated
and exhausted from dealing with the crap
and you just if you're not careful you
just give up and go buy a car on
payments yeah but the most powerful
stories don't do it they're the ones who
who use that pain and they go this
situation sucks so badly and i'm going
to do it every day
again that's a good point inspiring
point very well done good stuff good
hour george it's been fun well done ben
and kelly in the booth i am dave ramsey
your host we will be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there is ultimately only one
way to financial peace and that's to
walk daily with the prince of peace
christ jesus
[Music]
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsey advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
you